[موسيقى]
اولا لابد من يكون رئيس قوي تكون امام او
هدف الدوله قيام الدوله الحقيقيه ثانيا
بالنسبه للمجموعات المسلحه والمليشيات انا
اعرفها جيدا واخبرها جيدا مستعدين
يعني ان يكونوا تحت الدوله وطاعه الدوله
على شرط لما يكونش فيه عمليات انتقاميه
منهم هم او محاسبه
يعني غير قانونيه
والسيء الاخر لابد يكون في عدل وانصاف اما
اللي حاصل الان انه في مجموعه في مكان
مائي اعطوها او يعطوها فلوس والمجموعه
الثانيه لا فهنا دائما يشعر هم بالظلم
ويشعروا بان هم الدوله ما تعاملش فيهم
معامله عادله وبينما الدوله يعني تحتاج
لهم في قتال الارهاب
[موسيقى]
اللي خلى المليشيات والمجموعات المسلحه
موجوده بهذا الشكل اللي هي سببين اول
الصراع والانقسام اللي كان والحمد لله
الان في خطوات المسلحه ثانيا اللي هي
الرئيس لما
بيستخدم المال من اجل كسب ولاياتهم او
السيطره عليهم هنا تبدا مشكله كما حدث مع
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه الوطنيه عباره عن
استخدمتهم بيع وشراء
وبالنسبه ارتباطات خارجيه صحيح هناك
ارتباطات خارجيه لكن هذه مهمه الامم
المتحده والمجتمع الدولي اذا كان يبوا
استقرار لليبيا لابد ان يكون هناك توافق
بينهم وان الارتباطات الخارجيه لابد يمكن
الحكومه الليبيه ويساعدوها بانها هي يعني
كل الدول تكف عن الاتصال بالميليشيات
مباشره لكن الوضع لم يستقر بعد